bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette quatrième session des
webinaires tout d'abord permettez moi de
vous souhaiter une très bonne année 2021
pour cette reprise des webinaires nous
allons aujourd'hui aborder la
manipulation avancé de données avec le
avec deep lier pour vous donner quelques
éléments de contexte
nous l'avons vu depuis plusieurs séances
que nous abordons essentiellement ce
qu'on appelle le taille diverse qui donc
un un ensemble de package et parmi les
paquets judaïque diverses deep laier a
pour vocation d'aider à faire des
opérations de base sur les tableaux de
données de pouvoir sélectionner des
lignes sélectionner des colonnes trier
un tableau ou encore faire de la fusion
entre des tables donc deep la guerre va
être en fait c'est vraiment un élément
central de du tailles diverses
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que la
logique de dix plats hier c'est de
proposer de faire les différentes
opérations à l'aide de verbes donc
l'idée 1 c'est dans la philosophie de
tailles diverses chaque fonction porte
le nom d'un verbe chaque photo chaque
fonction fait une chose et une seule
chose et on va pouvoir enchaîner les
différentes fonctions sur nos tableaux
de données chaque verbe d'oedipe laier
va prendre d'entrée un tableau de
données il peut s'agir d'un data from
classique ou bien d'un thimble on l'a vu
en et ibl ce sont les tableaux de
données améliorée du taï duteil diverses
et ça va renvoyer un petit bol et donc
on va enchaîner ses opérations sur les
types
alors tout d'abord ce que je vous
propose c'est de vous partager mon écran
comme d'habitude un vous n'hésitez pas
au besoin à poser vos questions dans le
chatt youtube
et puis je ferai des petites pauses à
intervalle régulier
donc là vous avez donc mon écran et donc
ce que je vous propose c'est de
commencer
tout d'abord par charge et 10 plats hier
alors dit plat hier on peut le charger
directement comme tous les package en
faisant simplement library deep la
guerre mais on l'a vu la plupart des
paquets du tech diverses peuvent être
chargées directement à une seule fois
avec l'opération library taille diverse
donc si vous faites la grippe tailles
diverses
ça vous changera les paquet ggp lot 2
pour les graphiques thibault tyler
wheeler for cats frikat piur ainsi que
le package vip laier s'il n'était pas
déjà chargé donc plutôt que d'avoir à
faire library da player vous pouvez
directement faire un live politiques
diverses
pour rappel un dip la fière c'est la
partie gestion de données ti belle c'est
le format des tableaux taille d'hier on
l'abordera un peu plus tard s'est
restructuré les tableaux withers et
l'import de fichiers texte pius et de la
programmation stringer manipulation de
fiches de variables textuel for cats
manipulation de facteurs et ggp lot 2 la
gestion des graphiques
alors pour la session d'aujourd'hui on
va également reprendre un certain nombre
de donner d'exemples qui vont nous
servir pour varier un petit peu les
exemples aujourd'hui nous appelons
utilisé des données qui viennent d'un
package qui s'appelle n y c'est flights
alors je vais déjà le charger en mémoire
y ait en fait donc ce package en a pour
vocation principale que de donner des
données et les jeux de données en
question
correspondent à tous les vols aériens au
départ d'un des trois aéroports de new
york en 2013 et il a la particularité
d'être répartis entre trois tables
flights qui contient des informations
sur les vols date de départ destinations
aux horaires donc la commande data
flights pour charger le fichier en
mémoire voyez il est maintenant ici et
si je fais view de flights on va pouvoir
le regarder c'est donc un fichier qui à
336 mille observation pour dix neuf
colonnes vous avez hier membres
tu es donc si vous n'avez que le jour du
vol dép times et leur au départ
chime c'est l'heure de départ prévue et
donc vous avez un retard au départ donc
là par exemple y est que ce premier vol
est parti avec deux minutes de retard
vous avez une heure d'arrivée alors ses
côtés en fait en minutes 1 depuis le
début de la journée c'est un format un
petit peu particulier et vous avez
l'heure prévue d'arrivée on peut
calculer du coup un retard à l'arrivée
et puis quand un vol arrive en avance
comme ici avec ce -18 c'est un vol qui
arrivait avait que 18 minutes d'avancé
un car il correspond à la compagnie le
numéro de vol interne homme ça doit être
un numéro d'appareils
vous avez le code aéroport d'origine le
code aéroports de destination ainsi que
la distance en miles et la durée en
heure minute
donc là on a eu un vol de 5 heures 15
minutes soit un total je pense de 227
minutes probable si on fait point
d'interrogation flights vous obtenez
normalement des précisions sur
chacune des différentes variables ainsi
on voit représente que les heures sont
indiquées en fait en heure heure minute
un détail mais ivault shine et doivent
pouvoir être converti d'une manière ou
d'une autre
alors on va aussi avoir besoin on va à
charger un deuxième fichier qui
s'appelle data apôtres donc si je vous
fais un view un pote donc airports lui
contient une observation par aéroport
donc vous avez en fait est fait le code
aéroports le nom de l'aéroport latitude
longitude altitude time zone
donc là on à 1458 aéroports là dedans
pour rappel les vols qui était indiqué
dans flight sont les vols au départ ou à
l'arrivée de new york est donc là vous
avez jfk amy a donc un rôle qui va de la
reporte jfk à la report et mia et s'ils
ont vu des détails sur ces aéroports on
peut les trouver du coup dans la table
et repos tu si je cherche et mia c'est
donc mais miami indian un chemin enfin
le dernier jeu de données qu'on va
utiliser ses airlines et donc je vous
montre les rhein ce et donc c'est une
table tout simple mais qui contient une
observation par compagnies aériennes et
vous avez le code compagnies aériennes
avec le nom de la compagnie aérienne a
qui vous est donnée tout simplement ce
qu'on voit c'est que et art vérifier
mais je crois qu'il n'y a que les vols
internes amérique qui sont indiqués dans
ce dans ce tableau alors nous avons du
coup maintenant 3 3 jeux de données et
nous allons commencer à aborder les tout
premiers airs de deep lier avec les
verbes qui vont permettre de
sélectionner seulement certaines
observations on verra après les verbes
qui vont nous permettre de sélectionner
uniquement des variables de faire du
calcul sur les variables ou encore de
trier le fichier en fait qu'on est en
train de voir c'est que on avait abordé
syntaxe classique r avec la fameuse
syntaxe des crochets et là on va pouvoir
faire la même chose mais en utilisant
une syntaxe dit playa alors le tout
premier verbe s'appelle slice donc un
verre de déplaire on va donner son nom
donc je vais appeler ce live ça prend
toujours en premier lieu un nom de
tableau donc supposons que je prenne
airports et ensuite je vais indiquer le
numéro de ligne qui m'intéresse dans ce
live permet de sélectionner des
observations par rapport à leur position
dans le fichier donc si je veux la 10e
ligne
je vais faire slice airport 10 pour
rappel à la même chose aurait pu être
fait avec capote 10,1 entre crochets qui
renvoie aussi la même ligne donc cela
c'est l'équivalent de l'indexation par
position et avec ce live on peut aussi
dire je veux les lignes 10 à 45
on peut aussi donner plusieurs valeurs
si je fais 10 12 14
j'obtiens la 10e la 12e et la 14e ligne
vous voyez que un autre élément c'est
que dans la syntaxe du plat hier il ya
une certaine souplesse alors que dans
les crochets j'aurais dû faire un
vecteur qui contient les valeurs 10 12
et 14 que j'aurai passé je vous le fais
ici airport
ils auraient dû mettre ces
10,12 14 la virgule ici entre les
crochets pour dire que j'ai une
indexation sur les lignes et les
colonnes et j'aurai obtenu la même chose
avec ce live j'aurais pu lui passer un
vecteur de position faire slice importe
ce est entré un vecteur qui contient les
valeurs 10 12 et 14
mais je peux aussi tout simplement faire
cette écriture plus légère qui est de
donner différents vecteurs de position
est en fait dit player va prendre en
compte tous les éléments les uns avec
les autres
pour rappel quand on est un vecteur de
position aussi le stocker dans un objet
j'ai aussi j'aurais aussi pu faire je
crée un vecteur pause qui contient 10 12
et 14
et je peux faire slice de report ce
poste
j'obtiens encore une fois elle a
toujours les mêmes éléments alors là
j'ai appelé slice à chaque fois
n'oubliez pas pour le moment ça
m'affiche un résultat à l'écran mais si
je ne sauvegarde pas mon résultat
il est simplement perdu si je veux
garder du coup un sous-échantillon qui
contient uniquement la 10e à la 12e et
la 14e ligne il faut que je pense à
récupérer ça par exemple dire le
résultat je le stock dans un objet que
j'appelle tmp donc là je vais vous
donner pas mal d'exemples avec les
verbes sans sauvegarde et à chaque fois
le résultat mais n'oubliez jamais que
vous demandez un résultat et si on le
sauvegarde pas ils s'affichent à l'écran
et si on veut le se regarde et il faut
bien sûr passer par l'assignation la
petite flèche pour sauvegarder ce
résultat alors slice qu'ils évitent
l'équivalent de l'indexation par par
position on verra on utilise assez peu
ce qui est plus intéressant quand on a
un jeu donné ses pouvoirs sectionnés sur
des des conditions c'est-à-dire des
lignes qui vont remplir certaines
certaines certaines conditions et ça ça
se fait avec filter supposons que j'ai
donc mon fichier pour un fichier flights
avec tous les volets je voudrais avoir
uniquement les vols du mois de janvier
je vous rappelle la syntaxe classique
c'est de faire preuve ce entre crochets
met ma condition donc ses impôts de
dollars mof égale égale 1,1 alors qu'est
ce que j'ai fait une petite erreur on
reprend non c'est pardon excusez moi
c'est pas ce rapport ce que je
travaillais c'est sûr c'est sur les vols
donc ce fichier flights donc je reprends
flights crochet flights de la marne
égale égale 1,11 je vous rappelle dont
la syntaxe classique
si je veux conserver uniquement les vols
du mois de janvier je vais du coup faire
une condition je vais passer entre
crochets sur un tableau il faut faire
crochet virgule crochet pour donner la
condition sur les lignes la condition
sur les colonnes et l'âge une condition
sur les lignes et pour écrire ma
condition je dois redire d'où vient la
variable monde c'est pour ça que je
réécris flights dollar man of voyez
c'est un petit peu laborieux à écrire si
je veux faire la même chose avec des
plats hier je vais écrire filter flights
donc c'est le jeu de données sur lequel
je fais ma sélection et ma condition va
s'écrire tout simplement membre égal
égal 1
et le premier gros avantage de 10 plats
hier c'est que dix plats hier comprend
le nom des variables en contexte
c'est-à-dire quand j'écris filter
flights 1,9 égale égal 1
il va regarder est-ce que membre est une
variable dans le contexte de l'objet
flight autrement dit est-ce que c'est
une colonne de l'objet flight
si oui il va prendre la colonne de
l'objet flight et si jamais ils ne le
trouvent pas dans l'économie et fly qui
va regarder si j'ai en mémoire un objet
qui s'appelle manch mais ce gros
avantage là c'est qu'on a une écriture
qui est beaucoup plus facile et beaucoup
plus courte
on peut bien sûr écrire des conditions
un petit peu plus compliqué supposons
que je cherche les vols avec un retard
au départ entre 10 et 15 minutes
1 je vais faire filter flights et donc
c'est la variable retard cdeps délais
donc le retard au départ supérieures ou
égales à 10 est inférieur ou égal à 15
là je sélectionne les 14 9 les quatorze
1919 vol avec un retard au départ
compris entre 10 et 15 minutes inclus
pour rappel le symbole est lé père lui
est le ou ce qu'on appelle le et
commerciale permet de faire une
condition et il faut que les deux côtés
de la condition soit remplie et pour
faire une condition où on a recours la
part verticale qui s'obtient avec ald
ger 6 sur un clavier windows je vous
fais un exemple si je veux les re ceux
qui sont partis en avance donc un retard
au départ inférieur à zéro ou
[Musique]
les vols qui ont eu plus de plus d'une
heure de retard
si je fais ça ma condition cdep délai
inférieur à zéro ou des délais
supérieurs à 60 et donc on va retenir
les lignes qui remplissent l'une ou
l'autre des conditions
alors si on veut être précis et sur nos
conditions on va utiliser lé père lui
est où le symbole où il faut retenir
néanmoins qu'on peut aussi à filter lui
passé plusieurs conditions et si je fais
filter flights depp inférieur supérieur
ou égal à 10 et ep délai inférieur ou
égal à quinze donc la voie il n'y a pas
de symboles et en fait j'ai donné deux
conditions séparées par des virgules
il faut savoir que filter si on lui
passe plusieurs conditions là les
considérer comme des conditions et donc
ça c'est un point important
un des éléments qui est aussi
intéressant c'est que dit player permet
de faire aussi du qu'un peu de calcul à
la volée supposons qu'on s'intéresse aux
vols les plus longs les vols les plus
longs ce sont donc ceux dont la distance
de vol est égale au maximum de la
distance eh bien on peut tout à fait
faire ce calcul à la volée et faire un
filter flights tels que distance égale
égal
max de distance donc la voyez on va
pouvoir faire des choses un petit peu
plus subtil avec filter ce que je vous
montre ce sont uniquement les les la
pole au mans les éléments de base et les
herbes de base
si on veut un peu plus d'infos une fois
qu'on sait le verbe qui nous intéresse
il faut savoir qu'il ya souvent des
options additionnelles
et quand on veut aller plus loin dans la
maîtrise de deep la guerre on peut bien
sûr aller regarder l'aide si je vais
regarder le fichier des de filter et ben
on vous pourrez voir éventuellement des
choses un petit peu plus subtil à
l'intérieur puisque on propose par
exemple des between tenir des fonctions
additionnelles pour faire du pour faire
de la recherche est donc vous pourrez
trouver des choses parfois un peu plus
poussée dans la dans la partie dans la
partie fichiers dead mais retenait que
au quotidien et pour les besoins de base
tout ce qu'on est en train de vous re
aujourd'hui vous sera équivalente
alors avant de passer aux sections sur
les colonnes voyons voir les messages du
forum
alors il y à une première question c'est
peut-on appeler une ligne par
identifiant plutôt que par numéro de
ligne par exemple s'il en est un numéro
de passion dans une base de données
hospitalières
on peut le faire mais mec alors une
petite précision dans un tableau
classique et vous verrez peut-être dans
de la syntaxe ou l'écriture de base dans
r il est possible d'aider non ligne avec
des eaux brown et ims et dans ce cas là
avec les crochets on peut y passer un
nom de ligne quand on travaille avec des
tilleuls
on en a plus de nom de ligne on
considère qu' on va plutôt stockées là
si on veut avoir la formation à la
stocker dans une colonne par contre
supposons que vous avez votre fichier un
fichier de données qui s'appelle dès que
dans votre fichier donner des vous avez
une variable avec l'identifiant
l'identifiant du patient et bien vous
pouvez faire simplement filter des
telles que idées et galeux 4521 et donc
sélectionner un patient sur son
identifiant consiste tout simplement à
réaliser une section sur la variable
identifiantes ski
passé que vous aurez parfois si vous
avez un fichier passion vous aurez à
priori un seul résultat
par contre si jamais vous travaillez le
spam sur le fichier de visite médicale
va vous pourriez avoir plusieurs visites
pourraient même passion mais l'idée c2c
de passer ainsi d'ailleurs j'en profite
aussi pour vous dire que si vous
travaillez sur des fichiers un petit peu
compliqué il vaut mieux ne pas avoir de
verrières qui s'appelle idée mais un des
plus explicites par exemple y des
patients est il des visites et de faire
en sorte que vos identifiants soient les
mêmes d'une table à l'autre par exemple
vous avez pour y avoir une table visite
dans qu'il y aurait ainsi des visites
qui serait identifiant unique de la
visite est un nid des patients qui sera
le même identifiant que celui dans le
fichier patients alors deuxième question
la fonction soap set était équivalente à
filter et est ce qu'elle est plus
restreinte alors là la fonction soap 7
elle est effectivement tout à fait
qu'ils valentin je vous rappelle ses
obsèques
comment elle s'écrie c'est une fonction
de base de m supposons que je refasse la
même chose je veux récupérer une partie
des
alors je veux extraire deux mon fichier
flights les vols qui sont partis en
avance donc c'est dave délai inférieur à
0 l'autre élément c'est que seuls 7 tout
comme dix plats hier d'ailleurs tient
compte des variables en contexte voyez
ici j'écris des délais et
cette aide a compris qu edf délai était
à comprendre dans le contexte du tableau
flights et donc on faisait référence à
une des colonnes du tableau flight donc
pour le coup sont 7es filter sont ici
équivalente
par contre seul set je pourrai pas lui
faire une deuxième condition par exemple
ceux qui sont partis avec cinq minutes
et des délais inférieurs à 5 là ça ne
marcherait pas il faudrait en fait
passer de conditions alors est ce qu'il
ya une grosse différence entre 7,7 et à
filters filter est dans la logique du
dip la fière et on verra on pourra
facilement la mélanger à d'autres 7,7
c'est en fait une méthode qui pète un
peu générique qui marche sur les
sur les tableaux de données mais qu'on
peut aussi utiliser parfois sur d'autres
fraudes objet c'est une une fonction en
fait un peu générique ça marche sur des
matrices je crois qu'il peut y avoir en
fait des des probablement des petites
nuances sur sur les n a alors ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on va compte que j'en
profite pour présenter c'est la question
des valeurs manquantes
parce que ça des enjeux un peu importe
on alors supposons que je reprenne
flights qui va lui créer des valeurs
manquantes
alors je vais prendre flights et je vais
prendre la variable des délais mais je
vais considérer j'ai modifié je vais
qu'il valeurs manquantes sur les
premières lignes donc là je vais mettre
sur les 20 premières lignes je vais leur
mettre une valeur blanc compte d'accord
donc je vous présente un flight il est
là et maintenant on a du coup dnas sur
les premières lignes pas des suivantes
maintenant supposons que je sélectionne
et puis je faire un fichier un peu plus
petit je vais je vais faire un fichier
tombent d'accord et je vais prendre ce
live du coup de flight on va prendre que
les 50 premières les 50 premiers observe
les 100 premières observations d'accord
donc tmp 1 c les 100 premiers vols et
des délais pourquoi il ya moins sept ici
pourquoi j'ai pu de mon camp
non pas bon je n'ai pris qu'une seule
observation je veux prendre les 100
premières observations 1 à 100 voilà
donc tmb maintenant contient sans
observation d'accord les 100 premières
observations et on sait qu'il ya vingt
valeurs manquantes dans des délais ça va
jusque là une fois que j'ai posés çà si
en syntaxe classique
j'écrivais je veux les vols parti en
avance d'accord donc en syntaxe
classique c'était mp et c'est elle que
tp délai est inférieur à zéro
alors vous voyez j'ai 74 observations
qui sont apparus je vais on va faire un
view là dessus pour voir qu'est ce qui
fait il m'a pris toutes les observations
tels que des modèles a été bien
inférieure à 0 mais il m'a pris aussi
les valeurs manquantes
parce que quand je fais la condition
d'être délai inférieur à 0,6 des délais
mon compte je ne peux pas répondre à la
question et avec les crochets ce que
vous obtenez s'est du coup des valeurs
manquantes
maintenant supposons que je fasse un
seul set tmp tels que depp délai est
inférieur à zéro
l'intérêt de 7,7 voyez ici je n'ai plus
que 54 observation parce que quand on
fait un seul set
la condition c'est les valeurs pour
lesquelles ces éléments qu en sont
exclus alors qu'avec un crochet vous
avez des manquants et pareil si vous
faites la même chose avec un filtre nos
comptes ou cas ce que vous pouvez
retenir c'est que l'intérêt de ce
concept et de filter sait que sa
seleccion les lignes qui remplissent la
condition alors qu'avec une syntaxe
classique en crochet vous sélectionnez
des lignes qui remplissent la condition
ou pour lesquels la condition est
manquante
et si on voulait en fait
faire le calcul de manière classique
avec les crochets j'aurais dû rajouter
et is then à tmp tep délais avec n'est
pas mankono j'ajoute un point
d'exclamation et là j'aurais eu la même
chose donc
retenez bien l'intérêt aussi de filter
par rapport à une syntaxe classique
c'est qu'on va bien récupérer uniquement
les variables qui remplissent la
condition et vous n'avez pas vous
trimballer des manquants après est-ce
qu'ils vont m'utiliser pts 7 ou filter
je vous dirai si vous travaillez avec
des plats hier les autres verbes
déployèrent rester sur filter par contre
parfois pour d'autres types d'objets
vous pourrez être amené à utiliser ses
obsèques pour un résultat peu près
équivalent il ya peut-être des petites
subtilités j'avoue que de mémoire je les
ai pas mais éventuellement chercher sur
internet je pense que si vous tapez
s'observe erstfeld ça sur rci que vous
aurez probablement des gens qui se sont
posés la question de manière plus fine
probablement en anglais autre petite
question qui nous est posée est ce que
je pourrais dès lors changer la valeur
des données sectionné avec la flèche
alors non on va voir à plus tard comment
est ce qu'on fait pour changer des
valeurs
mais on ne peut pas faire cette syntaxe
de la delà de la flèche qu'on mélange
avec les crochets les dièses samar
chacun sa taxe crochet diez pas avec
deep lier avec des plats hier on va
passer par d'autres manières de refaire
s'être co2 là alors je vous propose de
passer au verbe suivant on a vu comment
sélectionner des observations mais ce
qui va être tout aussi intéressant et
une plus grosse partie du travail que
l'on va faire au quotidien ça va être en
fait de sélectionner des variables alors
pour 6 et des variables la principale
fonction s'appelle tout simplement
select supposons qu'on prenne le fichier
airports et je veux que les variables
latitude longitude
je prends le verbe select je vais donc
mettre le nom de mon fichier de données
impose donc retenu le premier argument
de tous les verbes dix plats hier c'est
systématiquement fichiers de données
c'est le fichier sur lequel on travaille
puis les éléments sur lequel on va
appliquer notre sélection et c'est un
avantage c'est que c'est du coup
uniforme d'andorre du plat hier là où
dans d'autres paquets de journée sur
d'autres choses et puis je vais
maintenant de dire qu'est ce que je veux
sectionné ben je veux la variable lattes
est la variable l'onu autre avantage je
vous remets la même chose en syntaxe
classique serait été apôtres crochet
virgule un vecteur qui contient les noms
et c'est important
donc l'avantagé de passer par la syntaxe
elect c'est qu'on n'a pas besoin de
mettre les guillemets c'est beaucoup
plus simple on peut tout simplement dire
on veut c'est variable là mais on va
voir qu'on peut aller beaucoup plus loin
avec avec select par exemple supposons
qu'on veut tout sauf ces deux variables
là eh ben pour explorer variable c'est
assez compliqué avec la syntaxe
classique de dix plats hier on avait vu
que quand on a des positions peut dire -
12 moins 10 pour dire tout sauf ces
lignes là mais ça marche pas avec les
noms et bien avec dix plats hier on peut
faire tout simplement ceci donc je fais
select airport - lattes moins long et je
sélectionne directement toutes les
variables sauf latitude et longitude
autre élément c'est l'acte fournit pas
mal del pearls qui permettent de
sélectionner les variables supposons que
je reprenne le fichier flash alors je
vous rappelle un petit verre qui
pourvoit avoir un vide aperçu sur un
objet c'est glims que proposent-ils
playart donc j'ai offert un petit
glimpse de flight pour qu'on se rappelle
ce qu'il contient on a toute une série
de variables et voyez il ya pas mal de
variables qui correspondent au départ
qui commence par des panzers score et
puis des variables pour l'arrivée
supposons que ce qui m'intéresse ce sont
toutes les variables du départ eh bien
je vais pouvoir faire select flights et
là je pouvais utiliser un helpers qui
s'appelle select star juive et donc
starts weave entre guillemets depp et là
je sélectionne toutes les variables dont
le nom commence par depp est donc dans
certains cas lorsque vous avez certains
gros fichiers de données que vous avez
des variables je sais pas moi la lave et
0,43 avait 0,43 bv 0,43 cv 0,43 des
jusqu'à le fg wesh
vous pouvez très rapidement dire je veux
toutes les variables qui commence par
vers 0 43
alors on peut en plus combiner nos
différents éléments
je vais les variables qui commence par
depp et puis je veux la variable heures
et puis je veux la variable flights donc
on peut mettre une série de conditions
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
a pas mal del pearls et d'écriture par
exemple je vous remets flights supposons
que je voudrais les variables qui vont
de des adeptes
ce groupe de variables là et bien vous
savez quand on veut faire des chiffres
qui suivent on écrit 12.6 pour dire 1 3
4 5 6 et ben dis plat hier propos ce
type de syntaxe dont je peux écrire
sélect dans flight comme je voulais dit
je veux aller de des as d'est j'écris
des deux poings d'est et ilham sectionné
toutes les variables qui vont de la
variable des jusqu'à la variable d'est
alors si on regarde l'aide de select
vous verrez en fait un certain nombre de
choses
vous avez les deux points pour
sectionner une suite de variables vous
avez le point d'exclamation for taking
complément à 27'' variés bourse
ça veut dire que si je représente cette
commande et que je faisais point
d'exclamation ça voudrait dire tout sauf
manière d'un versier on peut écrire des
sélections et des intersections d'union
de groupes de variables ya vraiment des
choses intéressantes
et puis voyez starts prive les variables
qui commence par un préfixe hands with
les variables qui finissent par un
suffixe contains pour les variables qui
ont un certain nombre pour des choses
plus compliquées on peut fournir une
expression régulière j'aborderai pas ça
ce soir mais oui on peut aller un peu
plus loin on peut ni moins le match des
numéros orange donc à chaque foyer des
exemples et puis vous avez aussi des
choses intéressantes comme where par
exemple je veux uniquement les variables
type textuel ce qui en a d'ailleurs dans
flight où les variables qui sont
entières des les entier je peux faire
select flights ware et là on passe une
fonction de test et is integer thèse si
un vecteur est un entier
et là en fait je vais choisir uniquement
les variables qui sont entières donc on
peut aller assez loin
vous avez aussi aux arv qui sélectionne
tout un groupe de variables mais il faut
que tout soit présent sinon aura message
d'erreur et any of qui va prendre celles
qui font partie du groupe mais sans
fermer sa g ainsi un exemple qui n'est
pas là je vous montre un usage vous avez
votre tableau flights d'accord puis
supposons je vais écrire vers un vecteur
qui contient le nom des variables que
j'ai envie d'inclure de mon analyse
donc je vais prendre par exemple mof
test d'aps times et puis je mettre une
variable à qui n'existe pas qui
s'appelle kompany donc là j'ai stocké en
fait d'enlever une liste de variables et
bien je peux sélectionner les variables
qui lie à bombay c'est à dire que si je
fais select flights v il va me dire il
n'y a pas de variables v6 jamais mais
l'homme dit regarder si on veut utiliser
un vecteur extérieur faute iseo l'envi
donc par contre si je fais all of vie ça
veut dire toutes les variables dont le
nom est contenue dans v l'aï va me le
faire mais il me dit à problèmes la
variable compagnie n'existe pas et donc
il renvoie une erreur et si je fais any
of vie eh bien il va me prendre celle
qui existe et puis ça qui n'existent pas
sont sont pas renvoyés tout simplement
donc voyez on peut commencer à faire des
choses un petit peu plus poussée et un
petit peu plus facile avec ce select
alors sachez aussi qu'il y a select
permet aussi d'une certaine manière de
renommée à la volée je vais vous faire
un exemple
je re vous montre glimpse je vous montre
le fichier flight est ce que j'aimerais
c'est prendre dont je vais vous prendre
part dont airport
est ce que je veux faire je veux prendre
la lentille la latitude et la longitude
mais les chronos mais en même temps si
je fais select airport lat long je suis
en train de sélectionner mes deux
variables et si j'utilise des noms je
vais faire l'attitude égale lattes et
longitude égale long à la volée je vais
renommer les variables un autre élément
qui peut être intéressant c'est de
vouloir sélectionner c'est de changer
l'ordre des variables si je fais select
airports long l'ate
en fait je sors dans l'ordre où j'ai
fait mais supposons que les justes
mètres que l'on est l'attitude au début
mais je vais garder toutes les autres
variables qui existent on peut avoir
recours à everything everything ça veut
dire sélectionner toutes les variables
qui raison fichiers et donc du coup en
fait je passe par select pour changer
l'ordre de mes différentes variables
alors on va regarder rapidement les
commentaires alors quel raccourci
utilisez-vous souvent pour supprimer les
lignes de commandes que vous avez tapé
alors effectivement à intervalles
réguliers j'essaye d'effacer l'écran et
j'utilise contrôle elle alors contrôler
elle efface l'écran ça c'est juste
effacer ce qu'on a dans la console pour
remettre un peu plus propre et en fait
ça correspond à ce petit bouton la clair
qu'on ne saurons le petit balai oui je
vais je tapais des choses j'essaie petit
balai en haut à droite je clique dessus
ça arrive face la console tout
simplement
et quand je garde la souris dessus on me
rappelle le raccourci qui est contrôle
elle
alors ce que vous pouvez aussi retenir
c'est que là une partie de ce que je
vous ai dit il n'y a pas besoin de se
rappeler de tous par exemple si vous
souvenez plus de stats wuhan rives
il suffit à un moment donné d'aller
regarder l'aide de select et puis si on
veut des exemples pu pousser je peux
regarder par exemple à l'aide de ware et
qui va me renvoyer je vais voir d'autres
exemples et on va voir jusqu'où on peut
aller on peut faire des choses assez
assez poussée là je vous présente
vraiment les éléments de base mais l'a
par exemple vous avez une sélection de
deux variables qui sont numériques est
dans la moyenne est supérieure à trois
demis on peut faire des choses en fait
un peu plus poussé avec avec le ton vous
avez dans l'aide
je vous rappelle qu'ils cheat pour avoir
accès à des feuilles de triche
bullshit pour toutes les voir mais vous
avez notamment data transformation bip
l'arrière qui télécharge un un pdf et je
vais vous l'ouvrir
je vous le mets à l'écran ce que je vous
dis là vous vous lavez
tata manipuler qu'aziz non cela il s'est
présenté ici à hyrule select
mais vous avez quelque part normalement
tout ce que je vous dis est présenté là
en fait ça c'est de petites feuilles là
elle est intéressante à avoir parce que
avec l'usa je voudrais vous arriverez
les retrouver et ça vous rappelle en
fait la variété inde et des verbes
disponibles et puis après il suffit
d'aller ben voilà c'est l'acte est là
d'accord donc c'est l'acte pour extraire
une variable et et vous avez contender
wine and big one love starts with
ametchi donc vous retrouver en fait les
différents éléments qui sont qui sont
ici vous voyez d'ailleurs qui a aussi
une fonction poe
alors juste aussi pour la petite
subtilité si vous regardez quand je
sélectionne une seule variable
si je fais select flight step dealait ça
me renvoie un tableau de données avec
une seule colonne si je fais pour sar me
renvoie le vecteur vous vous souvenez
l'histoire des crochets simple à
décrocher double donc là on a ces
éléments là alors toujours sur la
manipulation des colonnes très
rapidement de petites fonctions quand
même aussi à connaître qui sont win et
win m c'est juste pour renommer une
variable on change pas les positions
donc que je vais prendre par exemple
bartz winning
la porte et puis je vais faire du coup
l'attitude égale lattes
ça me renvoie en fait mon tableau
inchangé dans le même ordre
c'est juste qu'on a changé le nom de la
variable dont queen et me permet
facilement de renommer une variable
encore une fois la ces dans l'export que
c'est renommée si je veux que ça soit
modifiée de manière permanente il faut
que je pense à sauvegarder les résultats
dans leur box
n'oubliez pas et vous avez aux wildcats
qui est un peu ce qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure qui permet juste de re des
places et une variable
si je fais bride of fates airports l'on
en fait ça me positionne la colonne long
en premier et toutes les autres derrière
donc ces choses qu'on aurait pu faire
avec le sélect et le et le le dip la
guerre alors on met le nouveau nom de la
variable avant l'ancien oui dandy pas
hier c'est une règle générale un gros
sound c'est à dire je veux que
l'attitude soit égal à lattes faut se
dire comme ça c'est une sorte de mode de
calcul pour son souvenir
je veux et si vous avez un doute dans
tous les cas en fait à l'usagé ça vient
assez vite et si vous avez un doute vous
regarder directement directement dans
l'aide et vous verrez les exemples alors
je vois qu'il ya une question sur est ce
que dit playa permet d'organiser les
observations d'une base en fonction
d'une variable conteneurs date la
question c'est sans risque on peut trier
avec des plats hier oui mais on le verra
tout à l'heure
alors avant d'aller plus loin il ya
quand même un élément important c'est
l'enchaînement des opérations
normalement vous devez vous souvenir
on a abordé la semaine la dernière fois
le pape alors je vais vous représentez
le parpaing mais pour le coup ce que je
vais faire je vais sortir un petit
script je vais créer un script voilà des
mots du pape comme ça vous pourrez voir
et ses sauvegardes
donc j'ai un script supposons que je
veux sélectionner les
je veux sélectionnés et
les vols parti en avance je veux garder
que 10 et je ne veux que les que
certaines variables
donc ça revient à faire on a dit prendre
les vols
je vais donc déjà filter d'accord pour
sélectionner les vols dont depp délai
est inférieur à zéro
tout ça ça me renvoie
du coup les vols parti en avance je ne
vais garder que disent donc slice et je
prends les vols de 1 à 10 est apte
là-dessus ce que je veux faire c'est
garder que certaines variables donc
select et pardon j'oubliais de m
le fichier de données au départ donc ça
c'est flight est sûre flights on va du
coup sélectionner la variable ce que je
veux c'est le mois et le jour donc là
cette commande là donc je prends flight
on applique filters de sucer les
parenthèses verte ici avec dave délai
inférieur à 0 puis on applique slice
pour prendre les dix premières lignes
puis j'appris select pour sélectionner
les colonnes moi m'ont aidé ce qu'on
voit c'est que quand je commence à
enchaîner les opérations ça devient
difficile à lire une astuce d'accord
c'est ce qu'on va stockées dans un
fichier temporaire donc je vais faire un
fichier des qui va être égal à filter
flight depp délais puis je vais faire
l'opération qui consiste à faire slice
de d1 2.10 jeu sauf dans des haies en
suite je fais sélect des mof des donc si
je vais donc là c'est l'opération une
seule ligne mais c'est pas du fait
difficile à lire là je fais une
opération étape par étape
je prends flight je prends les vols qui
sont partis en avance puis je prends les
dix premières lignes puis je choisis les
variables mois et jours c'est plus
facile a su parce que je vois les
opérations dans leur ordre naturel alors
que la jouait les verbes à l'envers
malgré tout c'est un petit peu lourd à
écrire tout l'intérêt du pape donc le
piper je vous l'avait présentée la
semaine des as il ya le pardon avant les
vacances le pape c'est ce symbole là
alors pour rappel quand on fait x hype f
y d'accord ça c'est équivalent à faire f
2 x y
l'idée du pipe c'est que l'objet qu'on
passe avant le pape on le passe comme
premier argument de la fonction à la
suite ça peut paraître peut-être un
petit peu compliqué à première vue et
voyez comme on va pouvoir écrire tout ça
donc des ça va être je pars du tableau
flights j'applique le pipe et pour
faciliter je vais retourner à la ligne
je suis après un opérateur pas de souci
pour l'exécuter et donc ça va être
filter depp délai inférieur à 0 je n'ai
pas besoin de mettre flightpath que le
flight houllier va être passée au début
du film thor le résultat du fils tard
j'avais le paseo slice où on va faire un
dix
et du coup on suit select man of day
donc en fait cette troisième écriture
est équivalente à la deuxième qui est
équivalente à la première c'est juste
que du coup en enchaînant les opérations
on va avoir quelque chose de plus facile
à suivre on va mieux comprendre qu'on
est en train de faire je pars d'un objet
je lui applique une action j'applique
une action j'applique une action ne pas
oublier que si on veut sauvegarder tout
ça au début il faut penser à mettre la
flèche assignation dans un objet d
d'accord est en fête
du coup comme on pas assez donné de faux
d'étape en étape j'ai pas besoin de
répéter donc ce qui reste dans les
parenthèses en fait c'est le détail du
filter donc si vous regardez ça en
termes de lecture c'est je prends
l'objet flights je filtre sur des
modèles inférieurs à zéro je coupe pour
ne garder que ledit première ligne et je
choisis les colonnes mois et des antes m
c'est beaucoup plus proche de ce qu'on
dirait à la voie en termes de
vocabulaire
alors maintenant qu'on a vu cette petite
qu'on a revu rapidement le la
réorganisation je vous propose de
continuer notre exploration des verbes
de dix plats hier et pour répondre à une
des questions qui étaient posées tout à
l'heure justement comment fait-on pour
trier le fichier alors pour trier le
fichier il y à un verbe dédié à sa qui
s'appelle arrache donc on va grandir ici
on va partir
si on veut par exemple trier notre
fichier sur les vols en fonction du
retard au départ je vais prendre flights
donc là je vais vous écrire avec le
'pipeline' skype
j'appelle orange et je donne la variable
de tri
donc là vous récupérer le fichier flight
triés par valeur croissante de la
variable désilets l'avarié a fait une
variable textuel ce sera un tri
alphabétique alors attention s'il ya des
accents et des enjeux particuliers en
unicode sur le tri alphabétique antilles
accents contient pas d'accent ça va
plutôt bien puisque sachez que le tri le
fabricant français c'est pas le même
qu'en russe ou que donc divers langue
juste pour ça si vous avez une variable
numérique et ben on va être par valeur
croissante et si jamais vous avez une
variable type date on abordera dans une
future session on peut tout à fait
étriller par date croissante ou par date
décroissante
alors on peut aussi trier sur deux
variables
supposons que je fasse un tri par mois
puis au sein d'un mois par jour donc si
je mets à la demande t on commence à
trié par la variable mois puis pour les
égalités ont trait sur la variable était
jusque là rien de très compliqué
supposons que je veux de nouveau triés
sur le retard au départ mais j'aimerais
avoir au début les vols qui ont le plus
de retard donc cette fois ci on part sur
des petits lait et on va rajouter en
fait d es et pour des sending orgeur et
là en fait ça nous fait toujours un tri
sur la dette dilemme mais de manière
décroissante et donc du coup vous avez
en premier les vols qui ont le plus de
retard
et là on voit un vol qui a eu mille
trois cents une minute de retard ce qui
nous fait donc 21 heures de retard je
plains les personnes sur ce vol 1
alors pour le tri en fait ça se fait
assez facilement vous l'avez vu on va
aborder
comment on va faire un petit peu de
calcul sur les variables et là on va
l'aborder de manière assez simple mais
on ira plus loin la semaine prochaine
sur leur codage des variables mais pour
modifier une variable on va avoir
recours à newton donc la fonction you
take permet de modifier une variable on
va prendre tout de suite un premier
règle un premier exemple dans le fichier
apporte ce vous avez l'altitude mais
l'altitude nous est donnée en pied et on
aimerait bien voir une altitude ans m
donc je vais prendre airports je vais
appeler à t'engager aux médecins pour
que ce soit plus lisible et bien adapté
j'ai voulu mettront mon exemple donc
airports je vais faire un beauty et ça
s'écrit sous la forme non de la variable
égal fonction de calcul donc par exemple
halte m
pour créer la variable altitude en
maître qui sera égal à la variable halte
/ 3 points 28 08
et si je veut sauvegarder mon résultat
et bien j'ai intérêt à mettre tout il
faut que je pense à re sauvegarder mon
résultat
donc là dans la porte j'ai créé une
nouvelle variable qui s'appelle halte
aime et qui contient l'altitude en
maître si je fais un glims
sur airport vous voyez j'ai cette
nouvelle variable qui a été créé six
haltes m existait déjà bon on va tout
simplement remplacer la variable qui est
inexistante
on peut aussi à enchaîner les opérations
supposons que je parte du voeu de flight
je vais faire mieux tate
je vais créer la distance nous est
donnée en maïs dont je vais faire une
distance en kilomètres qui va donc est
égal à distance je me trompe ici c'est
les voilà donc flights jeu paille puis
muté distance km qui est égale du coup à
distance / 0.60 237 pour passer en fête
du maïs au kilomètre et puis bah on peut
tout de suite enchaîné des calculs et
supposons que je vais calcul est ici une
variable que j'appelais vitesse vitesse
va être distance en kilomètres
/ r times qui le temps passé en l'air
sauf que certains mais donnez minutes
dont je verrai x 60 pour avoir des
kilomètres heure donc en fait on peut
enchaîner dans un même minute et
plusieurs calculs et on peut la sur la
deuxièmee utiliser une variable que l'on
vient de créer à la ligne d'avants
puisque les calculs sont faits les uns
après les autres et puis pour que ce
soit plus facile à voir
je veux faire un select pour ne
présenter que les variables distance que
je ne crée une distance distance km et
vitesse
vous voyez on à la calculer directement
nos différentes commandes donc mieux
takes permet de faire du calcul ma
condition qu'on soit sous la forme de u
non variable est égal à un mode de
calcul
on verra en fait la semaine prochaine
sur la cession recreusage de variables
comme on va pouvoir faire pour traiter
des bars et catégorielles faire des
choses un petit peu plus fine avoir un
calcul qui serait différent entre les
hommes et les femmes par exemple si on
avait un indicateur et ce genre de
choses alors une un élément qui est
extrêmement puissant lorsqu'on travaille
avec un dip la guerre ce sont les
opérations groupées on va voir qu'on
peut
on va pouvoir faire des opérations par
ce groupe ce qui permet de gagner pas
mal de choses alors je m en dessous on
va agrandir le verbe groupe bail permet
de dire qu'on veut regrouper les données
selon une certaine manière
si je fais flights group buy
moi ça fait pas grand chose la seule
chose qu'on voit c'est qu'on nous dit
maintenant que le tableau est groupé par
mois par contre si j'enchaîne des
opérations les verbes suivant sauront
que l'opération doit être regroupés par
mois un exemple simple supposons que je
fasse maintenant slice 1 et donc en
faisant slice un sa veut dire je veux
prendre la première ligne mais le calcul
sera fait par mois et voyez j'obtiens
maintenant 12 observation pour chacun
des mois on a retenu la première ligne
alors ça peut avoir
d intérêt pour certains calculs
supposons que ce que je souhaite c'est
calculé un retard moyen par mois donc je
vais faire flights groupe
bail neuf minutes et ce alors moyenne du
moins qui est égal à mine de tep délai n
1 pour les féminines jouent et le
sauvegarde ça dans flight en faisant ça
j'ai regroupé par mois et j'ai calculé
une variable qui s'appelle à qui vaut la
moyenne du retard sauf que cette moyenne
aurait été calculés différemment par
mois si je regarde le tableau flights
voyez que pour ses premiers mois de
l'année j'ai une valeur ici mais si je
vais voir des observations bien plus bas
à un autre mois donné j'ai une autre
valeur sûre moyennement alors ce qui
s'est passé ici vous voyez on a eu
recours à une fonction qu'on appelle une
fonction de résumer les fonctions
moyenne somme médiane écart-type minimum
maximum ce sont des fonctions qui vont
prendre un vecteur de valeurs dont
plusieurs valeurs et qui en rend vois
qu'une seule ses fonctions de résumer si
gvt et utilise dans un mutisme comme on
l'a fait à cet endroit là à ce moment là
toutes les valeurs vont être envoyés
pour chacune des lignes donc là j'ai
toujours mes 300 milles mais 300 milles
mais trois cent mille lignes si ce que
je veux par contre c'est le calq et par
mois et garder plus qu'une seule
observation par groupe
on va avoir recours à la fonction
sunrise donc lorsque l'on a recours à
des fonctions de type résumé qui vont
réduire l'information on peut utiliser
ce mot wright plutôt calmes yutz et si
je fais flight games of sunrise moyenne
mois égale la moyenne des délais vous
avez ici le retard moyen au départ par
mois pour chacun des mois autre élément
on peut regrouper par plusieurs
variables et si je fais membres et des
pour chaque combinaison de mois et 2
jours je vais avoir un retard moyen au
départ et de m'envoyer en quelques
lignes de code je peux récupérer un
fichier avec les retards moyens jours
qui pourrait me servir pour faire une
série de graphiques par la suite ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que gros buy
est très intéressant pour ceux pour un
centre de calcul comme cela on peut
l'utiliser avec un sommer eyes ou avec
un mieux tête
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que lorsque
l'on à des fonctions de type résumé
c'est donc les fonctions qui prennent
plusieurs valeurs et n'en renvoient
qu'une
si on fait 1 mio tête on va répéter la
valeur obtenue pour chacune des lignes
si on fait ça me reiss on va du coup
faire un tableau synthétique
là où ça va prendre aussi tout son sens
c'est lorsqu'on va avoir recours aux
fonctions à fenêtre on a trois grands
types de fonctions ou d'opérateurs on a
les fonctions qui font un calcul ligne à
ligne
quand je prends deux vecteurs et que je
fais a + b g un vecteur à qui va
contenir 1 2 3 un vecteur b qui va
contenir 14 25
ils disent il manque le petit c est que
je fais a + b
j'ai pris trois valeurs en entrée trois
valeurs à côté je fais une opération
ligne à ligne et j'obtiens du coup
autant d'observations j'avais au départ
sauf que le calcul ne dépend pas de
toulouse de toutes les observations les
calculs et se fait à l'intérieur c'est
le 1 et le 14 qui sont mis en regard le
2,25
tout à l'heure lorsqu'on a calculé la
distance en mètres en kilomètres où la
vitesse moyenne du vol le calcul se fait
en fait uniquement que des valeurs de la
même ligne il existe les fonctions type
résumé qu'on ait vu la moyenne la somme
la médiane qui consiste à prendre toutes
les valeurs des différentes observations
et de fer incalculable avec elle pour
obtenir une unique valeur minimum
maximum moyenne st et puis on a ce qu'on
appelle les fonctions à fenêtres les
fonctions à fenêtres sont des fonctions
qui vont prendre un ensemble de valeurs
par exemple n valeur voulons envoyer end
valeur sauf que le calcul dépend des
valeurs voisines alors dit comme ça
c'est être pas forcément très clair mais
on a les fonctions en fait d'agrégation
par exemple une somme cumulée et ben en
fait là la valeur obtenue dépend des
observations précédentes
supposons que j'ai un vecteur v
6 1 4 6 7 8 9 et 1
et bien comme somme devait qui est la
somme cumulée va être 4 10 17 25 34 35
et donc du coup sûr ce type de fonction
à fenêtre c'est à dire dans les valeurs
dépendent des voisines l'ordre des
observations va être important alors que
lorsque je fais un calcul qui ne dépend
pas d'eux des valeurs voisines
peu importe comment j'ai trié mon
échantillon donc vous avez toutes les
fonctions de cumul qui sont assez
classiques quand vous avez comme sommes
calmes mine et que max si on combine de
v1 c'est le pain c'est le minimum
cumulés donc c'est le plus petit minimum
rencontré jusque là et vous avez que max
qui est le maximum cumul est donc là au
début il ya que 4 puis ensuite six 6 e
maximum 7 8 9 points sur 9 minimum 4 4 4
4 4 à 1
donc c'est le la plus petite valeur
jusqu'à cette étape la dip la guerre
étant ses fonctions cumul notamment avec
kumm mines gecamines en fait c'est la
moyenne cumulée donc l'a4 en faisant
mine près de 4 4 et 10 et ben en moyenne
ça fait 5 4 10 et 17 en moyenne ça fait
5 6 4 10 17 25 ça fait en moyenne 6
verrines 25 et ainsi de suite
vous avez ensuite les fonctions de rang
alors les rangs basse et quand on compte
le premier le deuxième le troisième le
quatrième et le cinquième le 6ème et
7ème le 8e si je reprends mon facteur v
d'accord le plus petit c'est le dernier
puis c'est le chiffre qu'a depuis ses 6
pi 6 7 puis 6 8 puis 6 9 vous avez une
vocation de bach qui s'appelle ranque
si je fais lang devait vous obtenez ce
si on vous dit bas 4 c'est la deuxième
valeur si cela troisième set la 4e'
mais huit sa 5e 9 la sixième et un la
première donc ça permet de trier dans
l'ordre jusque là tout va bien mais
quand vous commencez à avoir d égalité
ça devient un petit peu plus compliqué
alors on va changer un peu notre vais
donc vais y va contenir 2 4 1 2 7 3 4 de
je me raffy chevet et maintenant je
présente l'aide de la fonction wake et
vous avez ici ties méthode avec au
pardon ce que c'est moi avec les
différentes options possibles donc ties
méthode peut être average first
l'astronome max mines
voyons voir déjà par défaut donc par
défaut ce sera à breach si je fais rank
de v eh bien lorsque à égalité par
exemple ils les deux il y en a ils sont
3 1 de l'a1 de la et un dollar
et bien en fait leur position c'était
ils sont en deuxième troisième et
quatrième position et donc du coup on a
fait la moyenne des positions 2 3 4 en
moyenne 3 et on leur donnait 3 à tous
4 il est en sixième et en septième
position la moyenne c'est signe donc la
méthode à voyages consiste à prendre
tous les rangs et à leur appliquer
la moyenne vous avez ensuite first et
bien l'idée c'est qu'on va trier les en
fonction de l'ordre du vecteur donc ça
c'est le premier 2 le troisième deux
vétérans 3 et le 4 et le troisième de
est en rang 4 est donc en fait on prend
les rangs tous les deux sont en position
2 3 et 4
et on les trie dans l'ordre d'apparition
dans le fichier si je fais l'ast c'est
juste la même chose mais en inverse
c'est à dire que les deux vont être
classés 2 3 et 4
vous avez one d'hommes random on va
départager les deux de manière aléatoire
et puis enfin vous avez max et mines et
bon leur donne leur au minimum ou le
rang maximum si je fais mine
les deux sont en deuxième position et on
leur donne tous deuxième position
par contre les 3 e sont en cinquième
position et on leur donne la valeur 5
il n'y a pas une seule bonne méthode
pour le calcul des rangs mais il faut
juste retenir que
le calcul des rangs bas comme les autres
fonctions dépens des autres valeurs et
dépend de l'ordre du fichier d'un donc
les fonctions à fenêtre attention
l'ordre est important et puis suivant
cas de figure quand vous avez besoin
d'un rang il faut déterminer ce qui sera
le plus approprié
reste enfin un dernier type de fonction
à fenêtre mais qui sont extrêmement
importantes qui sont lead et l'ags lead
et l'ags c'est tout simplement
précédent suivant supposons vous avez
vais ici et si je fais
l'ide de v eh ben le lead ça vous donne
la valeur qui suit est donc forcément le
dernier la personne qui suit donc il ya
un manque on qu'arrive élague ça vous
donne la valeur qui précède
quel est l'intérêt de ça et bien
supposons que je crois que certains
d'entre vous ont des données un peu
clinique qui vous avez un fichier avec
les visites d'un patient
donc vous avez la date de visite vous
avez de fichiers vous avez vous allez
pouvoir trier votre fichier par dates de
visite et pour nos patients regardez
quelle est la date de la visite
précédente pour savoir le temps qu'il a
mis entre deux visites
si vous travaillez en fécondité vous
pouvez prendre du coup
un fichier de grossesse et regarder la
date de la grossesse précédente pour
calculer le délai entre deux grossesses
si vous travaillez sur d une base de
données des colliers
vous pourriez avoir les différents
examens et puis avoir la date une notes
d'examens la note de l'examen précédent
pour savoir si du coup l'élève à
améliorer ou baisser sa moyenne a donc
l'idée lag vont nous permettre de
récupérer des données précédentes sauf
que supposons que vous ayez à ficher de
visites d'accord donc vous auriez
plusieurs lignes par par individu et ce
qui se passe c'est que vous voulez pas
avoir pas demain visite d'une patiente
vous aurez voir le faire donc en fait
souvent lead lag maximum minimum quand
on veut faire part des sous groupes
on va besoin de le calculer petits
groupes par petits groupes
et c'est là en fait que le groupe buy va
devenir particulièrement intéressant
donc supposons que je m'intéresse si je
reprends mes vols d'accord donc on a une
variable qui nous dit la compagnie
career moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
faire une analyse par compagnie est bien
dans ce cas je pourrais faire flight
groupe et mon fichier par compagnie
trier les données par exemple justement
par par mois et par jour et la question
c'est de savoir est ce que le retard
d'un vol dépend du retard du vol
précédent d'accord donc ce que j'ai
besoin de récupérer c'est le retard
précédent donc me tate
mais de la même compagnie un adepte des
laits précédent alors je sais jamais
entre l'idée lag
alors moi je veux le président si je
fais lead de 1,4 j'obtiens donc lead
donne le suivant et l'ags me donne le
précédent donc je vais dire que des
délais précédent égale lag 2
depp délais donc là l'intérêt c'est que
le calcul sera fait au sein d'une même
compagnie et puis si en fait je me dis
oui mais en fait c'est chaque journée
est un événement indépendant donc ça
vaut pas le coup de calculer sa
séparément par jour je pourrai faire un
calcul uniquement par jour est donc
maintenant que j'ai calculé le délai
précédent je peux faire une quête je
peux regarder ce que ce qu'il ya
accroissement du retard et donc
l'accroissement bas c est ce que depp
délai est plus grand que depp délai
précédent alors car windows phone
comment s'appelle la variable car il
s'en est alors corrigeons j'exécute le
code donc l'âge aidant prix flight
groupes épars compagnie j'ai trié oui
j'ai trié en fait j'ai fait un bon
calcul par jour pour chaque compagnie et
pour chaque jour et je vais trier au
sein d'une journée par heure de la
journée des eps time pour avoir celui du
matin puis l'après midi donc là en fait
je regroupe je regarde je fais une
analyse par jour par compagnie je
regarde je trie mon fichier par heure de
départ dans la journée je regarde quel
est le retard au départ du vol qui
précède de la même compagnie et je
calcule une variable qui regardaient ce
que le vol le retard au départ de ce vol
là est plus important que celui du vol
précédent de la même journée
et bien sûr tout ça il faut que je le
sauvegarde si je veux le garder
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on veut regarder
on va faire une petite table rapide
de la variable qu'on a créés et la
question qui se pose c'est est-ce que le
retard a tendance à s'accroître
donc je vais prendre flights est la
variable accroissement alors on voit pas
forcément très bien
alors du coup je vais faire plus tôt
comme on l'a vu avec j 10 marie lee
brigitte sy se marient et donc du coup
je vais prendre flight
je vais garder que la variable
accroissement et j'avais fait mon tibia
sommes sa mairie
et je alors envoyé par défaut en fait
quand les données sont groupés dans le
sélect
ils me mettent toutes les variables de
groupements carl hayman et des est donc
là j'ai un tableau avec des choses dont
je ne veux pas ce que je voulais vous
dire c'est que une fois qu'on peut aussi
des groupes et un tableau une fois qu'on
n'a plus besoin et ça se fait tout
simplement avec un groupe donc ce que je
vais faire je des groupes
je n'ai plus que la variable
accroissement et là on voit 160 à 1118
avec 1 50% sur les 376 36 milles donc ça
veut dire donc la seule variable logique
donc on a en fait 50% des vols le retard
s'accroît mais il ya 50% des vols ou le
retarder crois donc qu'il n'y aurait pas
une certaine tendance au sein d'une même
journée pour le même compagnie à skis et
que les retards s'accumulent de plus en
plus dans la journée ouais on a répondu
à une grande question philosophale alors
les fonctions l'idée la gare il peut
vous paraître peut-être à ce stade un
petit peu un petit peu
théorique quand vous travaillez sur des
enquêtes transversale elles vont vous
servir
relativement peu mais à partir du moment
où vous travaillez sur des gros enquête
longitudinale avec beaucoup de données
par personne elles vont devenir
importante et c'est pour ça que pour
finir la session du jour je vous propose
que l'on aborde la question de la fusion
des tables donc la fusion tables
d'accord consiste à fusionner ensemble
différents tableaux et on a d'autres
types de fusion l'ajout d'observation et
l'ajout de variables alors ce que je
vais faire pour pour cette thématique là
je vais pas vous faire directement les
manipulations à l'écran pour pouvoir
vous présenter les choses un petit peu
plus clair je vais plutôt vous présenter
en fait la page analyse air consacrée à
la question alors on va voir les
différents types de jointure d'accord on
va d'abord avoir abordé la fonction mais
rj qui est la fonction de base dans aer
et après on verra comme on peut faire
avec dit playa mais la logique sont les
mêmes etc ce qui importe avant tout ici
c'est de bien comprendre la logique des
jointures
alors là on va simulé artificiellement
une situation là avec l' enquête hdv
2003 qu'on avait vus sur les séances
précédentes donc nous avons ici on a
chargé commissionnaires on appris à
gérer 2003 on l'a appelée d où on a un
tableau avec 2000 observations et 20
colonnes on a sélectionné alors sap
cette eau il peut aussi servir à
sectionner des colonnes
donc là on a sectionné en fait trois
colonnes idée âge et sexe
et puis on a fait un 2e objet d 2 avec
trois colonnes qui sont idées etc les
sauts et donc on a maintenant deux
tableaux de données d1 et d2 comportant
chacun de mes lignes et respectivement
trois et deux colonnes
la question c'est comment les rassembler
pour n'en former qu'un
intuitivement ça paraît simple on se dit
il faut juste collé de nos tableaux vous
avez ici votre premier tableau à gauche
on prend le deuxième tableau à droite et
on colle l'un à l'autre et on obtient le
tableau qui nous intéresse
ça semble fonctionner et il ya une
fonction qui permet réellement de faire
sainte que les deux tableaux côte à côte
elle s'appelle c'est bind elle colle des
tableaux côte à côte en regroupant leurs
colonnes et c'est pour colom buy in pour
coller jusque là ça marche à peu près
bien à part qu'on a la colonne
identifions qui est en doublant mais le
résultat sont pas malins mais c'est un
résultat est bien qu'à première vue
alors supposons qu'on mélange les des
nets d un sas et la syntaxe classique
avec hors dom et c'est le round gens
qu'on a vu avec eux des flyers est
maintenant au col de tableau ben voyons
et ça marche pas du tout parce que quand
on colle avec sibide là j'ai collé des
observations pour l'individu 162 avec
des observations pour l'individu 1 et
donc du coup ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
que la fonction si bind que vous verrez
parfois il faut la bannière à jamais
n'utiliser quand on veut fusionner des
données on doit absolument fusionner les
données en utilisant une variable
identifiant et d'ailleurs d'hier fournit
aussi un bankroll sans quelques erreurs
et bein vous oubliez à tout jamais alors
le principe c'est de le faire avec la
fonction merlan mêmes gens lui donne un
premier tableau un deuxième tableau et
on lui donne le nom d'une colonne qui
contient un identifiant comme un pur
pour fusionner et du coup là peu importe
dans quel ordre de tableaux sont triés
on va bien fusionner correctement les
bonnes observations avec les bonnes
personnes
et puis on va n'aura qu'une seule
colonne idées dans le résultat
alors ici
la fonction mer gèle marche bien parce
qu'on est dans un cas de figure idéal
les lignes corresponde parfaitement les
identifiant clairement identifié il n'y
a pas de trou mais parfois c'est un peu
plus compliqué parfois les identifiants
ils ont pas le même nom d'un tableau à
l'autre alors général c'est pas très
bien c'est pour ça que je vous
recommande que d'avoir un même identifié
un porte le même nom de variables dans
vos différentes tables mais parfois ce
n'est pas le cas on aura deux options un
pie x et bats y qui permettent de gérer
ça parfois les deux tableaux comporte
des colonnes ayant le même nom alors si
vous avez deux colonnes qui ont le même
nom dans vos deux tableaux merde je
valais conserver mais va en créer qui va
s'appeler point x et l'autre qui va
s'appeler de points y à l'usagé
normalement vous devriez pas avoir ça
donc avant de fusionner deux tableaux
vérifier ce que vous avez dans le
premier tableau vérifier ce que vous
avez dans le deuxième tableau
habituellement par exemple je vais avoir
un fichier de ma mort est un fichier
d'enfants et je veux récupérer des
informations de la maman dans le fichier
enfants on va faire un merde mais dans
la plupart des cas on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir toutes les variables du fichier
maman on aura juste besoin de deux trois
variables donc du coup ce que je vous
recommande grandement avant de faire une
fusion c'est de vous dire si je fais un
select pour retenir que les variables
qui vont servir à la fusion alors il ya
une subtilité supplémentaire
c'est lorsque d'auto tableau n'ont pas
exactement le même nombre de lignes par
défaut merde je ne conserve que les
lignes présente dans les deux tableaux
vous voyez un exemple ici j'ai un
premier tableau qui contient id inde les
individus 1 2 et 3 est la variable v1 et
un deuxième tableau qui a la une
variable v2 et les individus 1 2 et 5
par défaut mais rj si on marche sur
l'idée ne va fusionner que les individus
sains et deux parce qu'on les trouve des
deux côtés du tableau ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle un hymne à jiangyin pour
reprendre des termes est ce qu elle est
géré viendrait tout à l'heure parce que
c'est les termes convaincre
vpour pour pour des plats hier donc
hinault jawad si on ne garde que les
individus qui sont des deux côtés quand
on utilise mais rj on peut modifier ce
comportement avec all point x et au
point y un point x indique de conserver
toutes les lignes du premier tableau est
donc dans ce cas là on aura des valeurs
manquantes pour les lignes qui n'ont pas
d'équivalent dans second tableau par
exemple ici je fais je vais fusionné le
1er à bloc le second tableau avec
uniquement aux points x égale trop donc
c'est à dire on garde tous cas dans le
tableau de gauche on rajoute les données
du tableau droite quand on les a et on
met du mans consignes on sait ce qu'on
appelle aussi un lève tôt john ou fusion
par la gauche c'est à dire qu'on garde
tout ce qui lie à gauche et on complète
avec des informations de la droite
le wafd jaune ou un maire j'avais 15 au
point x égale trou sera probablement
celui que vous ferez le plus en termes
d'analysé enquête
l'idée en général si vous avez un gros
tableau par ma table aux enfants tableau
femmes sur lequel on vous rajoutez
quelques variables qui viennent une
seconde table et c'est uniquement cevam
là qu'on ajoute et par défaut vous
voulez pas changer le nombre
d'observations dans le premier tableau
donc c'est pour ça qu'on fera un match
par la gauche alors on peut aussi
utiliser uniquement au point y igal trou
c'est la même chose on fait ce qu'on
appelle un wright jane c'est juste la
même chose mais de manière inversée et
puis on peut aussi choisir hommes
pointent xxi galles troué au point y
ingalls chaud c'est ce qui s'appelle un
feu jaune et donc on va garder toutes
les observations qui viennent de la
gauche ou de la droite en créant le cas
échéant des valeurs manquantes là on a
des trous et donc cette différence entre
inner john neff john dryden of food
jaune
elle est très importante et donc quand
vous préparez une fusion de table prenez
bien le temps de réfléchir à qu'est ce
que vous voulez rajouter à quoi
et d'autant plus que les choses se
compliquent un peu lorsqu un identifiant
et présent à plusieurs reprises dans
l'un des tableaux par exemple lorsqu'une
mine tablette un ensemble de ménage et
que l'autre décrit les membres de ces
ménages
d'accord vous avez ici une table avec
des chefs de ménage et une table des
membres du ménage quand je fusionne les
deux eh bien voyez là la valeur h a été
répétée pour les trois lignes qui sont
présentes à l' usage en général on va
plutôt fusionner des données qui
viennent d'un ensemble plus grands vers
un ensemble plus loin d'un ensemble de
plus haut niveau vers un ensemble de
plus bas niveau c'est à dire que je vais
prendre des variables du fichier ménages
que je vais mettre sur mes individus par
contre je ne fusionnerait pas les
données du fichier individus sur le
ménage tiens je vais garder le même
nombre de ménages ce qui pourrait être
fait c'est sur mon fichier individus
calculer des variables par ménage donc
en résumant la formation permet nages
par exemple je pourrais calculer un
nombre de membres du ménage
donc en fait je pars du fichier membres
du ménage pour calculer une variable au
niveau du ménage
et maintenant que j'ai une variable au
niveau du ménage peu la fusionner dans
mon tableau ménages alors encore une
fois prenez toujours bien temps quand
vous travaillez avec différents niveaux
hiérarchiques dans vos analyses
à bien réfléchir à qu'est ce qu'on met à
quel niveau et comment on organise donc
la fonction ce fait on l'a vu par défaut
avec la fonction merde et on rajoute
simplement les options all points x et
au point grey qui a tout on peut faire
avec dix plats hier à peu près même
chose le principe c'est que par défaut
c'est par exemple pour faire une fusion
à gauche on va faire left john flights
airlines donc là je vais fusionner mais
de fichiers ensemble
par contre c'est pas bien de le faire si
vous faites lève john flight airlines
ont précisé une clé de jointure d'hier
sera organisée à vous dire d'ailleurs
qui la joue qui va chercher s'il ya une
variable qui porte le même nom s'il ya
plusieurs variables qui porte le même
nom et à vous dire joining par câble et
ça c'est bien pour aller vite mais
idéalement vous devez donner une clé
explicite est donc la clé explicite se
fait tout simplement en indiquant by
égale nonda variable on peut aussi
utiliser des variables qu'on pas tout à
fait le même nom là vous est un cas de
figure je vais fusionner ce fichier là
avec ce fichier là sauf que la variable
s'appelle origine dans un fichier et f à
adam l'autre fichier est donc dans ce
cas là en fait on passe à un vecteur
nommé pour indiquer la fusion entre les
deux encore une fois y'a pas besoin de
retenir toussaint le joint vous ai
besoin de faire une voiture allait
regarder lettre détaillée de left john
alors les types de jointures on les
avait déjà abordé tout à l'heure lève
tôt john ça correspondait tout à l'heure
aux all by ikks égale y vous avez de
manière équivalente
le white john et vahid jeunes de xy ce
équivalent à left joring de xy de geeks
et une faute l'un d'ailleurs innovision
sait on garde toutes les lignes présente
à la fois dans x et dans y est full john
c'est toutes les lignes 2 x et toutes
les lignes de y qui sont conservés donc
en fait c'est la même chose que les au
point x hall
enfin vous avez aussi
deux autres fonctions qui peuvent être
intéressants qui sont fait ce qu'on
appelle les jointures filtrantes
en fait ça va sélectionner des lignes de
x sans ajouter de cologne 2 y y
en fait ce me john lorsqu'on a une
variante de voitures permet de conserver
les lignes 2 x pour lesquels il existe
une ligne dans y est anti jo il permet
de sélectionner les lignes 2 x qui ne
sont pas présentes dans y donc sur sur
les jointures sur les jointures retenait
que quand on veut rajouter des variables
lève d'orgue le plus courant inner john
paul jones prenait bien le temps et
idéalement pensée a bien spécifié
quand vous faites votre appel on va
reprendre un exemple de 2
de bien penser à préciser que je vous
mets à l'aide de left john est bien
français a précisé le paramètre bail
pour ça pour bien être explicitement sur
la variable qui vous intéresse et éviter
au maximum les erreurs donc éviter les
jointures implicite m'ont dit pas le nom
des clés et essayer de penser aux bonnes
pratiques
voilà bah c'est un exemple tout sublimé
par john ivison indiqué explicitement le
nom la variable de jointure et on nous
précise bien que c'est une bonne
pratique en termes de code de production
et c'est une bonne manière pour vous
éviter de faire des erreurs
reste la question de la fusion
d'observation donc supposons que vous
avez deux fichiers vous voulez fusionner
les observations ensemble eh bien vous
verrez parfois une fonction airs bind
dans aer et il faut éviter à bail parce
que c'est le même problème qu on avait
tout à l'heure avec ses bind hairband ne
tient pas compte que si les variables
sont peut-être pas dans le même ordre
dans deux tableaux c'est pour ça que la
bonne manière de procéder est passé par
bayrou ce donc là on va avoir un exemple
un jeu vous créez vous avez t1 t2 et t3
qui sont trois tableaux différents
donc tu es tous sont pris de airport et
je crois pas me garder les mêmes les
mêmes noms de variables oui on va faire
tout simplement pas une rose t1 t2 t3 l'
avantage c'est que quand on fait
malheureuse bas il va vérifier les
variables qui en commun si elles sont
pas dans le même ordre bas c'est pas
grave il a bien refusionner les données
avec il va vous prévenir s'il ya un
problème de ben oui mais là c'est une
variable numérique alors que l'aah les
ailes et textuelle et puis surtout si
jamais eu énormément content il va
correctement créer des valeurs
manquantes donc pour fusionner des
données les observations ensemble bein
bros
mais attention pas rigoureuse ne
marchera correctement que si le nom des
variables et cohérent entre les trois
fichiers si vous et des fichiers dont
les variables ont même pas les mêmes non
ça ne fonctionnera pas autre option
c'est que on peut aussi vouloir savoir
d'où viennent nos fichiers et donc si
vous faites byword t1 t2 t3 et que vous
faites pour une idée égale source
ça va créer une nouvelle colonne qui
s'appelle source qui aura le numéro
d'identifiant du fichier donc un c pour
savoir les lignes qui venait de t1 de
levelling qui venait de t2 et ainsi de
suite
alors par défaut on obtient un nombre
mais si on veut quelque chose de plus
explicite on peut aussi nommer les
colonnes bein heureuse table un égal t1
table de galt et deux tables 3 gâtés 3
et la voilà on a rempli le tableau donc
retenait quand on a besoin de fusionner
l'ensemble passé par byron et si vous
avez besoin d'acheter observations de
manière un peu plus compliqué un peu
plus programmatique avec des listes vous
pourrez toujours passer par l'aide de
banyuls pour voir des choses un peu plus
d'avancé
alors je vous propose de finir là dessus
ce soir là je son qui est que c'est un
peu durant une heure et demie les
fusions et la manipulation vous
inquiétez pas là c'est un peu de théorie
ce qu'on a vu ce soir on le mettra en
oeuvre par la suite la semaine prochaine
on va aborder plus spécifiquement leur
codage de variables après on va faire de
l'analyse est l'heure de l'analyse on va
avoir besoin de tous ces outils là donc
les outils de manipulation de données de
codification ont l'air toujours
théorique à la base mais quand vous
serez plongé dedans ça vous sera utile
alors quelques questions pour finir la
soirée il y avait je crois de questions
sur une groupe pourrez vous reprendre la
commande en groupe et un petit retour
sur une groupe
donc je reprends rapidement supposons
que je prends le tableau flights à une
étape précédente j'avais groupé flights
avec carl hayman faisait donc maintenant
on a dit en fait c'est juste
on a dit il faut regrouper ces variables
à part ces trois valeurs il faut groupe
est stable au parc our most est donc à
chaque fois qu'on fera mieux tête
aaron john slice il le fera au sein des
groupes
et si on veut simplement dire je ne veux
plus groupé mais opération je veux
revenir juste un tableau entier eh ben
je vais faire flights en groupe et je
vais sauvegarder ça d'ailleurs
et quand je fais ça et je reprends
flights il n'est plus groupé donc ça
veut dire que si je faisais maintenant
un tri à cette étape là si je faisais un
triste sur le df délai par exemple le
retard au départ le trio aurait été fait
à l'intérieur de chaque campagne pour
chaque compagnie mois et jours donc en
fait mon fichier aurait été triés par
compagnie mois jours et à l'intérieur de
ces groupes là j'aurais eu mon tripard
retard au départ maintenant que c'est
des groupes et si je fais mon trépas
retard au départ il se fait sur
l'ensemble du fichier
alors ça sera peut-être un petit peu
plus clair quand on le fera par la suite
de toute façon en général plutôt intérêt
à dégrouper notre fichier une fois qu'on
a plus besoin c'est à dire que mon
groupe le fichier à un certain moment
donné pour certains calculs un peu
compliqué où ça fait sens et puis par la
suite on va des groupes et pour regarder
un fichier dans sa globalité
alors une question sur la fonctionnaire
j'étais un peu comme un index match sur
scène j'avoue sur excel je fais pas trop
de fusion je suppose que ça doit
correspondre
je vous avoue j'ai un usage excellent au
final assez limité pour ma part puisque
excellent me sert à faire sur mes petits
calculs mes petites bidouilles soyez va
servir plutôt à gérer un peu du stockage
de données de base mais les fusions des
frayeurs donc si ses index match sur
excel je suppose que c'est équivalent à
une fusion de table la fusion tables
c'est un problème qu'on trouve sur
l'ensemble des des enjeux de base de
données
et donc les inner junk food jeunes
élèves january jones et des choses que
vous retrouvez aussi pour ceux qui
connaissent on est ce qu elle sait
exactement la même chose et ensuite
quelles fonctions faut-il utiliser pour
effectuer le produit cartésien de deux
tables alors il faudrait peut-être me
définir le produit cartésienne de table
je suis pas sûr de 2pac bien comprendre
la question
je pense que vous faites référence à un
type de jointure spécifique frères
vérifier à quel jointures vous faites
référence particulier mais quand on fait
un mineur jeunes on a toutes les
combinaisons des variables identifiantes
mais je jouerai là pour le coup je n'ai
pas la réponse
de suite voilà en tout cas merci pour
cette 7 5 4e séance des webinaires
puisque je numérote pas les sessions
foire aux questions
encore un grand merci pour votre
attention pour votre écoute je sais que
ça fait des grosses sessions que c'est
parfois rapides surtout je vous invite à
ne pas hésiter à reprendre le temps de
regarder la vidéo au calme avec des
pauses pour essayer de dirt manipuler de
votre côté ce qui est aussi important
c'est n'est pas nécessaire de tout
retenir c'est vraiment lorsque vous
allez manipuler sur votre propre enquête
vous propres données qui a amené les
choses vont prendre plus de sens ce qui
est important par contre c'est que quand
vous voyez vos besoins dit ça là j'ai
besoin de faire ça j'ai vu quelque chose
qui ressemblait et que vous retrouviez à
quel endroit c'était et à ce moment là
vous allez voir plus spécifiquement la
documentation de la fonction ou chapitre
à la lisère ou revoir le passage de la
vidéo de webinaires donc il n'y a pas
besoin de tours connaître par coeur ce
qui est important c'est de retenir la
logique et comment on pourrait appliquer
au quotidien
la semaine prochaine nous nous
retrouvons jeudi 17h temps européen 16
heures en temps gmt on abordera tout ce
qui va être recollage de variables quand
on fait l'analyse des enquêtes en fait
on passe quasiment 90 à 95 % de son
temps à faire du rpt codage de variables
et 10% on va faire l'analyse proprement
dit mais ça nous permettra dans deux
semaines d'aborder la régression
logistique à être faire la modélisation
ce qui va devenir tout d'un coup un
petit peu plus excitant on abordera dans
un premier temps la régression
logistique
binaire la plus classique avec comme on
la mettre en oeuvre comment faire des
représentations graphiques et puis
comment calculer les effets et puis on
abordera en une deux séances les effets
d'interaction dans le modèle la
simplification du modèle par paralyser
ou d'autres éléments
voilà je vous souhaite une très très
bonne journée et puis ben écoutez je
vous dis à très bientôt
merci à vous